well we've talked earlier today about
cheshire and
amisham it was never a race that labour
expected to win but they still had a
pretty shocking night
losing their deposit let's talk about
that result and more with shadow
community secretary
steve reed
steve reed um the constituency labour
party
in uh cheshire and amisham has 629
followers on its facebook page
your candidate got 622 votes what what
happened to the other seven
well let's give her voters some credit
here
trevor because what what i think
happened is that voters took their own
decisions about the best way to defeat
the
conservative candidate in that
by-election so labour voters lent their
support to a liberal democrat who was
best positioned
that's never been a seat where labour's
been competitive it's never been a seat
where labour's done
particularly well you know voters took
their own decisions and they defeated
boris johnson and they
defeated him for very good reasons as
well but it's pretty grim isn't it i
mean this is a seat
55 percent remain 40 i think graduate
it's a sort of place that labor should
be doing well and
needs to do well if it's going to
compete
for government again isn't it worrying
that
if you look at pete in this area
if you look across what happened in the
local elections in the south of england
just a few weeks ago
labour won the mayoralty of the west of
england we picked up seats in
hertfordshire we picked up seats in
sussex we're increasing our vote in kent
labour is doing well across the blue
wall in this particular seat
it was the liberal democrats who were
competitive now in the general election
there will be only two alternatives for
prime minister boris johnson or
kia starmer so things may look
differently then as things were
on thursday the liberal democrats were
best placed to defeat the conservatives
and labor voters backed
the lib dem in order to get the tory out
and one of the reasons for that
was the hugely unpopular planning
reforms that the uh government is
bringing forward to deprive local people
of a
of any say over developments on their
own streets and in their own
neighborhood so
you know there is a growing coalition
across this country intent
on stopping the conservatives from
continuing uh on the path they're going
along
uh about this country's future
i want to come to the planning issue
because that's an area that i know you
are
uh expert in but let's just talk about
the politics about this
of this for another minute or so did i
understand from what you've just said
that
however informal however unspoken
you think that the possibility
of essentially an anti-tory alliance
uh exists that would see the
different parties the liberal democrats
the greens
the scottish national party essentially
combining
to get the tories out
well i didn't i didn't mean to imply
that at all uh trevor i i'm not myself
attracted you're talking
fundamentally about what's called the
progressive uh alliance so-called
and i'm not attracted at all to the idea
of politicians
trying to stitch up the choices
available to voters in their own
localities voters are smart
voters will take their own decision
amisham they they took the decision they
took and in the west of england they
took a different decision
the key for labor uh is to win a
majority across the country
the blue wall is clearly crumbling now
but we saw in hartlepool the labour
party is having problems still
in some parts of former industrial areas
in different parts of the country
we need to build out now a policy and a
program that has broad reach across the
whole of the country
to secure the election of a labour
majority government that
is what we are focused on not stitching
up deals with other parties to deprive
voters of choice
so for you it's a labor majority or
nothing no alliances with the snp
no understandings with the liberal
democrats
well this is you know it's in the hands
of the voters rather than me how they
uh choose to vote how they choose to
vote but what keir is doing at the
moment and we've seen
the changes he started to bring in over
the last few weeks is gearing the labour
party up to the next general election
he's appointed annalisa dodds to head up
a policy review
our intention is to build a policy prep
platform
attractive enough uh to win support from
across the country
from majority labor government that can
bring our party back together
after a decade in which the
conservatives have pulled our country
apart
and made us weaker both domestically and
on the world stage
well let's address policy um you said
that the planning issue was a major
uh question in cheshire and amisham
will labor support the government's
plans
to streamline the planning system
and to make it easier to build homes
and harder for people to object to new
developments
well as i'm sure you're aware we've
caught a vote in the
commons tomorrow uh on on some of what's
going on here and what the conservatives
are up to
is they've got a a flagship piece of
legislation that they're bringing
forward as part of
their new legislative program and what
it does it takes away
the rights of local people and local
communities
to object to developments that may be
happening in their localities power is
shifted
from elected councils on their planning
committees
to development boards that are appointed
by conservative ministers in whitehall
those development boards
then zone your locality either for
protection or for growth if you're zoned
for growth
then planning applications are deemed
accepted and even if you're going to see
a development on a green space like the
one i'm standing on now on or on the
street where you live
you as a resident lose the right to have
a say and to object
uh to that application this is a
significant reduction in people's rights
and the reason
the conservatives are doing this is
because under boris johnson's
leadership donations to the conservative
party from major developers have gone up
by 400 percent
so the conservatives are paying back
developers by selling out communities
and depriving communities of the right
to assay over development on their own
street now we're calling a vote tomorrow
in the house of commons yes
to guarantee the right of residents to
object and we're those conservative
mps who have stood up in the chamber so
far and said they don't like this
well put your money where your mouth is
because there's a vote tomorrow and you
can vote with us
to protect residents rights isn't the
outcome of all of that that essentially
labor is lining up with the nimbys who
say
we don't want new development in our
backyard even if that means
that young people who want to buy homes
there will be no homes
available for them isn't that
isn't that the outcome of what you've
just said
there's two points here trevor i've got
experience of this myself i used to
chair a regeneration board that
developed
that brought forward 5000 new homes the
best development happens
when developers local councils and
communities work together
it doesn't work well when all the power
is in the hands of the developers and
everybody else is silenced from
having a say but if you want to look at
what the real problem is in this country
that is stopping homes being built
it's not the planning system that the
government is trying to change because
over the last
10 years a million homes have been given
consent
to be built but were never built the
problem isn't the planning system the
problem is developers not then going
ahead
and building them and the reason some
developers do that is land that has a
planning
uh consent on it becomes more valuable
and some developers will
sit on that land wait for the land
values to rise and then seek to make a
profit by selling it on
without building the homes what we need
are better incentives to help developers
go ahead
and build the homes once they've got
consent not putting a gag around local
people's mouths
so they can't have a say about what
happens on the street where they live or
the community that they're part of
steve reed thank you for your clarity
this morning